[Musique]
la loi de finances est un texte énorme
un mastodonte qui arrive proposé par le
gouvernement ce texte concerne
directement notre vie de tous les jours
que ce soit la vie des citoyens des
usagers puisque on décide on fixe
notamment le barème de l'impôt sur le
revenu et par exemple
le groupe l'est républicain a soutenu
des mesures en faveur de la politique
familiale en relevant le montant du
quotient familial
c'est aussi la fiscalité de l'énergie
c'est aussi tout ce qui concerne la vie
de nos entreprises est cette année
particulièrement avec un certain nombre
de dispositifs de soutien à l'économie
la lecture de ce budget est extrêmement
compliqué parce que le gouvernement a
décidé certainement pour pouvoir
communiquer de mettre de côté 100
milliards de dépenses et pour faire ça
il est venu me n'aurait finalement les
crédits d'émission c'est dire les
crédits qui se sont je vais dire
conjoncturelle qui sont là pour faire
fonctionner l'état au quotidien et en
parallèle il ya eu l'abondement du plan
de relance mais parfois pour des actions
qui sont exactement les mêmes
donc voilà compliqué parce qu'on n'a
finalement deux vecteurs dont un qui est
censée être limitée dans le temps
le plan de relance on nous parle de 2021
donc aujourd'hui en fait la question
qu'on se pose c'est quid de 2023 est ce
que les moyens qui ont été supprimés
dans les missions qui ont vocation à
perdurer au delà de 2023 seront ré
abondé en à sentiment que le sénat était
un peu délaissé en plus en ce moment on
peut pas avoir l'excusé d'avoir piscine
puisqu'elles sont fermés mais
effectivement c'est très désobligeants
de constater que bruno le maire n'est
jamais venu alors même que c'est lui qui
est porteur du texte avec olivier du
soft et puis on a d'autres ministres par
exemple barbara pompiers mais n'est pas
venu pour les crédits de la mission
écologie
olivier ferrand n'est pas venu pour la
mission santé
si on regarde vraiment la mission
écologique est ce qui avait le plus
c'est effectivement cristallisé les
attentions c'était cet article
additionnel ajoutés par amendement du
gouvernement deux dernières minutes à
l'assemblée nationale à savoir une
remise en cause des contrats signés avec
l'état pour des installations
photovoltaïques de plus de 250 kilowatts
donc 250 kilowatts c'est en gros une
grosse voiture je remets pas en cause ce
que dénonce l'état à savoir une
rentabilité trop élevé mais ça j'ai
envie de dire l'état le savez puisque au
moment où il a signé les premiers
contrats il y avait déjà eu des avis de
vigilance voire d'émettre des avis
défavorable de la commission de
régulation de l'énergie
ce que j'ai dénoncée et en cela avec
tous ses nains parce que ça a été voté à
l'unanimité
c'est la remise en cause de la parole de
l'état il est vraiment important que la
parole de l'état reste quelque chose de
sûre de certains nous avons décidé de
supprimer de supprimer cet article
après sur la mission écologie de manière
plus globale il me semble qu'il faudrait
aller beaucoup plus loin plus tôt dans
le soutien là alors c'est à dire arriver
à faire baisser le coût de ses véhicules
arrivés à faire diminuer le coût des
matériaux à améliorer l'efficacité de la
rénovation thermique pour qu'on ait
finalement un marché qui trouve son
équilibre assez naturellement entre
offre et demande
[Musique]